can we take a slight tangent on that on
this topic of
it sounds like maybe you could speak to
the bigger picture
it sounds like you're quite
self-critical who charles
no you oh i think i can i can do better
i can do better i'll
try me again i'll i'll do better
[Laughter]
yeah that was like a like a three out of
ten responses
so let's try to work it up to five and
six i you know i remember
uh marvin minsky said uh on on a video
interview
something that the key to success in
academic research is to hate everything
you do
for some reason i think i followed that
because i hate everything he's done
[Laughter]
that's a good line that's a success
maybe that's a keeper but um but do you
do you find that resonates with you at
all in in how you think about talks and
so on
i would say it differently it's not not
really that's such an mit view of the
world though
so i remember i i remember talking about
this when uh as a student you know
you were basically told uh i will clean
it up for the purpose of the podcast
um uh my work is crap my work is crap my
work is crap my work is crap then you
like go to a conference or something
like everybody else's work is crap
everybody else's work is crap and you
feel better and better about it yeah
uh relatively speaking and then you sort
of keep working on it
i i don't hate my work that resonates
with me yes i've never hated my work
but i have i have been dissatisfied with
it
and i think being dissatisfied being
okay with the fact that you've taken a
positive step the derivative is positive
maybe even the second derivative is
positive that's important because that's
a part of the the hope right
but you have to but i haven't gotten
there yet if that's not there that i
haven't gotten there yet
then you know it's hard to it's hard to
move forward i think so i buy that
which is a little different from hating
everything that you do yeah i mean
there's
there's things that i've done that i
like better than i like myself
so it's separating me from the work
essentially so i think i am very
critical of myself
but sometimes the work i'm really
excited about and sometimes i think it
doesn't happen right away so i i found
the work that i've
liked that i've done most of it
i liked it in retrospect more when i was
far away from it in time
i have to be fairly excited about it to
get done
no excited at the time but then happy
with the result or but years later or
even i might go back you know what
that actually turned out to be yeah that
turned out to matter or oh gosh it turns
out i've been thinking about that
it's actually influenced all the work
that i've done since without realizing
it
but that guy was smart yeah that guy had
a future
yeah he's going places
i think there's so yeah so i think
there's something to it i think there's
something to the idea you gotta
you know hate what you do but it's not
quite hate it's just being unsatisfied
and different people motivate themselves
differently i don't happen to motivate
myself with self-loathing
i happen to motivate myself so you're
able to sit back and
be proud of in retrospect of the work
you've done
well and it's easier when you can
connect it with other people because
then you can be proud of them a lot of
the people
yeah and then the questions now you can
still safely hate yourself
it's a win-win michael or at least win
lose which is what you're looking for
oh wow there's so many brilliant
there's levels
you